floods
are ravaging different parts of kampala
different parts of uganda
and across the african continent
historically africa is responsible for
only three percent of global emissions
and yet africans are suffering some of
the most spiritual impacts fueled by the
climate crisis
but while the african continent
while the global south is on the front
lines of the climate crisis
they are not on the front pages of the
wild newspapers
we've seen activists from the most
affected areas
being erased
from pictures from conversations
and removed from rooms but how will we
have climate justice if people from the
most affected areas are not being
listened to
the climate crisis is here now
but
the dry land
can be glad again
the farms
can blossom again
the animals can rejoice because there is
water to drink
there is a loud singing
in once patched lands
the pain and suffering is gone
there is a celebration of the people
because the disasters are gone
our history is visible
there is no fear of losing it
we won't have to just tell our children
about our cultures because they will see
and experience them themselves
we won't have to fight for limited
resources because there will be enough
for everyone
there is food to drink there is food to
eat and water to drink
children can go to school with no fear
of dropping out
there is joy and singing because finally
no child can be forced into marriage
once flooded places will dry and bloom
again
there is triumph in the city because the
power of the people finally won
the world is green again
nature has been restored the planet and
creation is respected another world is
necessary another world is possible and
this is just a glimpse of it
and today
we shall continue to fight on in
everywhere we can
we cannot give up now
we need to continue holding leaders
accountable for their actions we cannot
keep quiet about climate injustice
your actions matter
no action is too small to make a
difference and no voice is too small to
make a difference
let us keep the faith for the future
which faith will give us the hope for
the world not yet seen but the world
that we can imagine the world that i
just told you about and above all the
love for the people and for the planet
three things should stay with us as we
continue to organize and mobilize and
strike and speak up and demand for
climate justice that is faith hope and
love and the greatest of these things is
love because when we continue to love
the people when we continue to love the
planet that will be the strength we need
to fight for a future that is
sustainable that is healthy that is
clean and equitable for all of us thank
you